[Music]
ah
don't worry i got it where is she where
is she where's who
came as fast as i could i cancelled all
my meetings what are you doing here uh
are you yelling where's tabitha
where is she tipped you're here you're
really here what time is it left or
right
is it your fibula talk to me good
dilation open up
what are you doing you look okay don't
worry i'm fine uncle's head
that's my girl woohoo what brings you
into town well tabitha fell off a pony
she did she did i did tim left me a
voicemail you did
i did you did hello this is your brother
help chavista fell off coursey goodnight
sweetie well that was unsettling
i swear i didn't leave that message
on purpose i i
died with my butt while i was talking my
sleep i do that sometimes
you sleep but dialed me with my butt
i'm running in the house hand over the
bottom
you can't have money you know
but you can tim you can
[Applause]
men am i right
it's not personal it's business
thanks so much for coming in ladies
would you like some fruit um
hey can we get on with this
i miss my teeth i've decided who's going
on the mission
thank you i accept both of you yes baby
core wants to get the team back together
huh
no they think that's a terrible idea of
course they do
well i'm the boss applesauce and i think
you two are better together than you are
apart
will i work alone or at least not with
him hey
there's no i in team actually there's no
you in team either
but there is an me but teamwork doesn't
seem work
ah if you want something done right do
it yourself we're all in a chicken
every man for himself one is the
loneliest number the eyes happen we're
the people
i'm trapped in the dum-dum holding tank
remember your panic attack get way out
of here
something doesn't smell right blueberry
i have to get out of here don't look at
me
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm sure this isn't something money
can't solve
what the fudge the baby
she's been sent from up there upstairs
that's right baby core
tim i'm gonna give you the name of a
doctor roy fetterman
just tell him i sent you you just don't
remember tell him tina
she can't talk i stop interrupting
interrupting what i don't hear anything
except your obnoxious voice you hear
that
i have a beautiful voice suck it ted
i thank your pardon you suck no no tim
you suck
suck it take a second it's fantastic out
of my face excuse me i hate to interrupt
suck it
a blast it's a lot of fun a lot of
shouting a lot of losing my voice
a lot of energy happening
eat your vegetables take a nap
you're gonna let grownups push you
around
there's almost no limit on what you can
do in this movie don't press pause
it's a much bigger party this time
around we really let it loose
it's the beginning of the baby
revolution now let's get some sleep
[Music]
the truth is
it's lonely at the top uncle ted that's
my girl
my baby brother ted all he cares about
is work but he always remembers to send
inappropriately lavish gifts
on special occasions
good night uncle ted i hope to grow up
and be a success just like you
good night don't you think i'm a little
old for that now
okay i'm afraid tabitha and i are
growing apart
like i did with my brother but you can't
turn back time can you
easy breezy taco peasy boy she can talk
a lot this formula will give you a
second chance of childhood
my texting here i'm better with this
kind of thing what kind of thing
everything
doesn't last forever but family sure
does hey we get on with this
i miss my teeth what's stressing you out
so much
my dad embarrassed of him oh it's not
that
i just wanted to be proud of me what
would you do everything tim did teddy
wanted to do
they were best friends would you stand
up and walk
when you wake up i will be there and you
and i
will always be brothers makes me want to
make a sad
face
we always stick together and that's what
families do
who wants to play shawshank on my signal
unleash
oh oh
[Music]
gross
[Music]
bye